Sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing results-driven mental health care for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28, who are struggling with trauma, depression, anxiety, and other mood personality and co-occurring disorders. At Newport Healthcare, tailored treatment plans foster sustainable healing to help young people move from struggling to thriving. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. Do you have secrets? Maybe you're looking to leave your job and don't want your co-workers or your boss to know. Maybe you still feel shame about cheating on an exam in high school. Maybe you haven't told anyone whom you voted for in the last election. Or perhaps a friend told you about an extramarital affair and swore you to secrecy.
由 Newport Healthcare 赞助，为 12 至 28 岁、正在与创伤、抑郁、焦虑以及其他情绪、人格和共病进行斗争的青少年和年轻人提供注重结果的精神健康护理。在 Newport Healthcare，量身定制的治疗计划可促进可持续的康复，帮助年轻人从挣扎走向繁荣。请访问 newporthealthcare.com 了解更多信息。你有秘密吗？也许你正打算离职，但又不想让同事或老板知道。也许你仍然对高中时考试作弊感到羞耻。也许你没有告诉任何人你在上次大选中投给了谁。或者，也许某个朋友向你讲述了一段婚外情，并要求你绝对保密。
We keep our own secrets and sometimes we keep those of others. Research has shown that on average people have about 13 secrets at any one time, five of which they have never told another person. How does this secret keeping affect us? People often describe secrets as burdens that weigh them down or eat away at them. Do these metaphors reflect a deeper truth? Does keeping a secret bottled up inside harm us? And if so, how?
我们都有自己的秘密，有时我们也会保守别人的秘密。研究表明，人们平均同时拥有大约 13 个秘密，其中有 5 个是从未告诉过别人的。保守秘密会如何影响我们？人们经常把秘密描述为压得他们喘不过气来或蚕食他们的负担。这些隐喻反映了更深层次的真相吗？将秘密憋在心里会伤害我们吗？如果是的话，又是如何伤害的呢？
How does keeping secrets or sharing them affect people's relationships with each other? How do we decide whom we can trust with our secrets? and can other people tell when we're holding something back. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Michael Slepian,
保守秘密或分享秘密如何影响人与人之间的关系？我们如何决定谁是可以托付秘密的人？别人能看出我们有所隐瞒吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是迈克尔·斯莱皮安（Michael Slepian）博士，
the Sanford C. Bernstein and Company Associate Professor of Leadership and Ethics at Columbia Business School. He's a research psychologist who studies the psychology of secrets. He examines the intersection of secrets. secrecy, trust, and motivation, including the consequences of secrecy, and how we judge and develop trust. His new book, The Secret Life of Secrets, How Our Inner World Shape Well-Being, Relationships, and Who We Are, is being released in June by Penguin Random House. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Slepian. Thanks for having me. So let's start with the number I quoted in the introduction,
他是哥伦比亚商学院 Sanford C. Bernstein & Co. 领导力与伦理学副教授。他是一名研究秘密心理学的研究心理学家。他研究秘密、保密、信任和动机的交集，包括保密的后果，以及我们如何判断和建立信任。他的新书《秘密的秘密生活：我们的内心世界如何塑造幸福、人际关系和我们是谁》（The Secret Life of Secrets, How Our Inner World Shape Well-Being, Relationships, and Who We Are）将于 6 月由企鹅兰登书屋（Penguin Random House）出版。谢谢你今天加入我们，斯莱皮安博士。谢谢邀请我。那么，让我们从我在引言中引用的数字开始，
that people keep about 13 secrets at any one time on average, and five of them they've never told anyone. Those numbers come from your research. Can you tell us about that study? How did you arrive at those numbers? Yeah. So when we first started this research, we didn't know, we didn't have the most basic questions yet answered, like, what secrets do people keep? How often did they keep them? And so we went to find out. We asked a couple thousand people, what is the secret you're currently keeping right now? And then we looked at the responses and looked at the themes and the common instances listed. And we saw 38 categories could really well capture what those folks said that they were keeping secret. And then when we gave this list to another group of participants, sure enough, 97% of them say they have at least one of the secrets from the list right now.
人们平均同时保留大约 13 个秘密，其中 5 个从未对任何人说过。这些数字来自你的研究。能给我们讲讲那项研究吗？你是如何得出这些数字的？是的。所以当我们刚开始这项研究时，我们还不知道，最基本的问题还没有得到解答，比如，人们保守什么秘密？他们保守秘密的频率是多少？于是我们去寻找答案。我们问了几千个人，你现在正在保守的秘密是什么？然后我们查看了回答，研究了主题和列出的常见情况。我们发现 38 个类别可以很好地概括这些人所说他们保守的秘密。然后，当我们把这份清单交给另一组参与者时，果然，其中 97% 的人表示他们现在拥有这份清单上的至少一个秘密。
And the average person has 13 of the secrets from that list at a given time, five of which they've never told anyone. And so these categories that we're talking about, they really comprehensively cover what people keep secret. when we ask people open-ended, what is the secret that you're keeping? 92% of the time it fits one of these categories. So what are some of the most common secrets that people keep? Yeah, so the most common secrets include having told a lie and you don't want that to become known. Romantic desire while you're not in a relationship, it is a very common secret. Money is another common secret, things related to sex.
普通人在特定时间拥有该清单上的 13 个秘密，其中 5 个他们从未告诉过任何人。我们谈论的这些类别确实全面涵盖了人们保守的秘密。当我们以开放式询问人们保守的秘密是什么时，92% 的情况下它符合这些类别之一。那么人们保守的最常见的秘密有哪些呢？是的，最常见的秘密包括说过谎，而你不想让这件事曝光。在没有恋爱关系时产生浪漫的渴望，这是一个非常常见的秘密。金钱是另一个常见的秘密，还有与性有关的事情。
So how do you define a secret? Is there a difference, for instance, between a secret and something that we just consider private? Yeah. And in fact, there can be some gray area between, but there's a way to draw a line between the two, which is that privacy tends to sort of focus on, you know, you don't broadcast personal information very, very widely if you're a private person. And if there's something that people don't know, it may be because these aren't the kinds of things we tend to talk about. So for a lot of folks, they don't talk about money or they don't talk about sex. And so that might be why people don't know those things about you.
那么你如何定义一个秘密呢？例如，秘密与我们仅仅认为是隐私的东西之间有什么区别？是的。事实上，两者之间可能存在一些灰色地带，但有一种方法可以划清界限，那就是隐私往往侧重于，如果你是一个注重隐私的人，你就不会非常广泛地广播个人信息。如果有些事情人们不知道，那可能是因为这些并不是我们倾向于谈论的事情。对于许多人来说，他们不谈论金钱，也不谈论性。所以这可能就是为什么人们不知道关于你的这些事情。
But when it becomes a secret, it's not just that someone doesn't know this thing about you, but it's that you intend for them to not learn this information. That's when we arrive at a secret. So let's talk for a minute about the intersection between lying and keeping a secret. For instance, I recently watched the movie, Dear Evan Hanson, where Evan creates this whole complicated fiction about having been friends with a schoolmate who has killed himself. The lies that Evan tells about the relationship are, they're very much like secrets. And they appear to be a heavy burden on him, much like secrets tend to be, only maybe more so because he never was friends with the other boy.
但当它变成一个秘密时，不仅仅是别人不知道关于你的这件事，而是你打算让他们不知道这个信息。这时我们就得到了一个秘密。让我们花一分钟讨论一下说谎和保守秘密之间的交集。例如，我最近看了电影《致埃文·汉森》（Dear Evan Hanson），其中埃文编造了一个复杂的虚构故事，说自己曾与一个自杀的校友是朋友。埃文关于这段关系的谎言非常类似于秘密。它们似乎对他构成了沉重的负担，就像秘密往往那样，只是可能更是如此，因为他从来没有和另一个男孩做过朋友。
So are lies just a different type of secret? So no, I would say that lying is one way you could keep a secret, but it's not the only way. There's plenty of secrets you can keep without telling lies. So a lie is one way out of many to keep a secret. And then, of course, you can keep a lie a secret. But there's sort of different constructs, but they're kind of intersecting in this way. A lot of your work has to do with how secrets affect us often in harmful ways. There's a line in an essay you wrote that said,
那么谎言只是不同类型的秘密吗？不，我会说谎言是保守秘密的一种方式，但不是唯一的方式。你可以保守很多秘密而不说谎。所以谎言是保守秘密的众多方法之一。然后，当然，你可以把一个谎言当成秘密。但这些是某种不同的结构，不过它们以这种方式交集。你的很多工作都与秘密如何经常以有害的方式影响我们有关。你写过的一篇文章中有一行说，
the real problem with having secrets is not that we have to hide them, but rather that we have to live with them. So why is living with secrets so difficult? What's so difficult about just simply having a secret, a secret that you might not ever have to hide in conversation, if it's something you care about or if it's something that's bothering you, to choose to be alone with that thing tends to not help. We tend to not develop the healthiest ways of thinking about these struggles we keep entirely to ourselves. And so even whether you're hiding it frequently or not, your mind is going to return to this thing time and time again, and you're not going to know what to do with us. Are there some types of secrets that are harder to live with at others? For example, you've looked at the difference between secrets that people consider shameful and those they feel guilty about is one worse than the other.
拥有秘密的真正问题不在于我们必须隐藏它们，而在于我们必须与它们共存。那么，为什么与秘密共存如此困难？仅仅拥有一个秘密有什么困难的？如果在谈话中你可能永远不需要隐藏这个秘密，如果这是你在乎的事情或者困扰你的事情，选择独自面对那件事往往没有帮助。对于我们完全独自保留的这些挣扎，我们往往无法发展出最健康的思考方式。因此，无论你是否频繁地隐藏它，你的大脑都会一次又一次地回到这件事上，而你将不知道该拿它怎么办。有些类型的秘密是否比其他秘密更难共存？例如，你研究了人们认为羞耻的秘密与感到内疚的秘密之间的区别，其中一个比另一个更糟吗？
Yeah, so in one sense, if we sort of ignored what our secrets are about, we could see that the secrets that return to our minds more frequently are the ones that are also related to low well-being, not the ones that. that we say we can seal more frequently. But when we look to what the secrets are about, we see this distinction that you mentioned between shame and guilt. And shame, we can consider someone, when someone feels a shame, they feel like I'm a bad person to some degree.
是的，从某种意义上说，如果我们某种程度上忽略我们的秘密是关于什么的，我们会发现那些更频繁地回到我们脑海中的秘密也是那些与低幸福感相关的秘密，而不是那些我们说更频繁隐藏的秘密。但当我们审视秘密的内容时，我们看到了你提到的羞耻和内疚之间的区别。对于羞耻，我们可以认为当某人感到羞耻时，他们会在某种程度上觉得自己是个坏人。
When someone feels guilty, they think I've done a bad thing. And so instead of thinking I'm a bad person, I've done a bad thing is actually much more healthy. And it's when people feel like I'm a bad person that they find their minds returning to the secret time and time again. And those are the secrets we say. sort of hurt our well-being the most.
当某人感到内疚时，他们会认为我做了一件坏事。因此，与觉得自己是个坏人相比，觉得自己做了一件坏事实际上要健康得多。正是在人们觉得自己是个坏人时，他们会发现自己的大脑一次又一次地回到这个秘密上。而这些就是我们所说的某种程度上对我们的幸福感伤害最大的秘密。
And how does keeping secrets harm us? Was there research that ties secrecy directly to poorer physical or mental health? So this is where things get tricky. Trying to link a specific secret to lower physical health is tough. And so, you know, there was a well-known study in the 90s that looked at men who were keeping their sexual orientation secret, who were also diagnosed with AIDS. And they found that the men who concealed their sexual orientation more often had a more rapid progression of disease and even died sooner. And so that's sort of a sobering idea.
那么保守秘密是如何伤害我们的呢？有没有研究将保密直接与较差的身心健康联系起来？所以这就是事情变得棘手的地方。试图将一个特定的秘密与较低的身体健康联系起来是很困难的。因此，你知道，在 90 年代有一项著名的研究，研究了那些对自己的性取向保密且也被诊断出患有艾滋病的男性。他们发现，更频繁地隐瞒自己性取向的男性，病情进展更快，甚至死得更早。所以这是一种清醒的看法。
But it doesn't mean it was the part, the hiding part that that was so bothers or troubling. That is when you, there's the moment in which you sort of conceal a secret during conversation, that turns out to be easier than we've made it out to be. But the real problem with this situation is not feeling comfortable enough to be yourself. And that's really very reliably related to low-re-being, feeling unsupported. And so it's having your mind return to ideas like that. I can't be who I am. I'm not supported for who I am. That seems to be where the trouble or where the harm really begins.
但这并不意味着正是隐藏的那部分让人如此烦恼或不安。也就是说，当你在谈话中隐瞒秘密的那一刻，事实证明这比我们想象的要容易。但这种情况下的真正问题是没有足够的舒适感来做自己。这实际上与低幸福感、感觉不到支持有着非常可靠的联系。因此，让你的大脑回到这样的想法：我不能成为我自己。我因我是谁而没有得到支持。这似乎才是麻烦或伤害真正开始的地方。
So is there a difference between keeping our own secrets and keeping a secret for someone else, such as one example I gave in the introduction about a friend who confesses an affair. Does keeping someone else's secrets feel as burdensome as keeping our own? It can. So if someone confides a secret in you and you have totally overlapping social networks, you're now essentially keeping the secret for them to you. Or if only certain people are allowed to know, it can get burdensome really quickly. But if it's something that's not directly relevant to some folks in your shared social,
那么，保守我们自己的秘密和为别人保守秘密（比如我在引言中给出的一个关于朋友坦白婚外情的朋友的例子）之间有什么区别吗？保守别人的秘密会像保守我们自己的秘密一样具有负担吗？会的。因此，如果有人向你吐露秘密，而你们有完全重叠的社交网络，你现在本质上就是在为他们向你保守秘密。或者，如果只允许某些人知道，它很快就会变得沉重。但如果这与你们共享社会的某些人没有直接关系，
network, it's not as difficult. When another person's secret becomes burdensome is when it becomes something we find our minds returning to time and time again. But there's a good side too. We feel glad that other people feel comfortable confiding in us. We see that as an active intimacy that brings us closer together. So sharing a secret then can bring people closer together or does it depend on the nature of the secret or even the person to whom? whom you've told it. Yeah. So, I mean, I'm imagining you're telling someone that you're already close to you. If it's someone you're not already close to you, it would be quite intimate, perhaps, to reveal something that you wouldn't tell just anyone. But again, it's a really great
网络，就不会那么困难。当另一个人的秘密变得沉重时，它就成了我们发现大脑一次又一次回到的东西。但也有好的一面。我们很高兴别人觉得可以放心地向我们倾诉。我们将这视为一种拉近彼此距离的亲密行为。那么，分享秘密可以拉近人们的距离，还是这取决于秘密的性质，甚至取决于你告诉的那个人？是的。所以，我的意思是，我假设你告诉的是一个你本来就很亲近的人。如果是一个你本来就不亲近的人，向一个你不会告诉任何人的事情透露可能会相当亲密。但话说回来，这是一个非常棒的
way to, like, jumpstart a relationship. Anyone who's, you know, trying to form a relationship quickly realizes that sort of revealing sensitive things, making yourself vulnerable is a way to connect with each other. What advice do you have for people who We're living with secrets that are weighing on them. How can they think about whether the risk of telling the secrets are worth the relief of being able to unburden themselves? So this is a question that is just so hard to answer on your own. And the good news is you don't have to. So you can still keep the secret from the person you're keeping it from.
方法，比如，启动一段关系。任何试图迅速建立关系的人都会意识到，透露敏感事情、让自己变得脆弱是彼此建立联系的一种方式。对于那些生活在压抑秘密中的人，你有什么建议？他们如何考虑说破秘密的风险是否值得卸下包袱所带来的解脱？所以这是一个很难独自回答的问题。好消息是你不必独自承担。所以你仍然可以对你一直对其保密的那个人保密。
But you can talk to a third party and say, like, what do you think I should do with this? it's so helpful to just have one more perspective than your own because it's really hard to step outside of your perspective, especially when you're not sure what to do. Talking to a third party is definitely what I would recommend in that situation. Sponsored by Newport Healthcare, dedicated to providing sustainable healing for young people struggling with mental health concerns so they can move from self-destruction to self-esteem. Based in compassion and driven by outcomes, Newport serves team. and young adults ages 12 to 28 at residential and outpatient programs nationwide.
但你可以和第三方谈谈，比如，你觉得我该怎么处理这个？仅仅拥有一个除了你自己的视角之外的另一个视角是如此有帮助，因为跳出你自己的视角真的很难，尤其是当你不知道该怎么做时。在这种情况下，与第三方交谈绝对是我会推荐的做法。由 Newport Healthcare 赞助，致力于为与心理健康问题作斗争的年轻人提供可持续的康复，以便他们能够从自我毁灭走向自尊。立足于同情心并由结果驱动，Newport 在全国各地的住宅和门诊项目中为青少年和 12 至 28 岁的年轻人服务。
Through tailored treatment and family support, Newport successfully addresses psychological and behavioral health issues, including depression, anxiety, PTSD, personality disorders, and substance abuse. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. So you've participated in a kind of public art project a few years ago where people could tell their secrets anonymously in a public phone installed in a park. Does that kind of anonymous sharing have the same effect? Will it make people feel better if you have a secret that you aren't ready to share with your friends or family? Is it helpful to tell it to a stranger or even write it in a diary or a journal? If you're truly not ready to tell anyone that you know or you just can't find
通过量身定制的治疗和家庭支持，Newport 成功解决心理和行为健康问题，包括抑郁、焦虑、创伤后应激障碍、人格障碍和药物滥用。请访问 newporthealthcare.com 了解更多信息。那么你几年前参与了一个公共艺术项目，人们可以在公园里安装的公共电话里匿名讲述他们的秘密。这种匿名分享有同样的效果吗？如果你有一个不准备与朋友或家人分享的秘密，这会让人感觉更好吗？把它告诉陌生人，甚至把它写在日记里会有帮助吗？如果你真的没有准备好告诉你认识的任何人，或者你只是无法让自己准备好谈论它，那么像这样的事情是一个好的开始。我不会说这是一切，但这是一个好的开始。有时只需要大声说出来，就会觉得，好吧，这是我可以处理或解决的事情。因此，无论你是在秘密电话上这样做，如果你碰巧在纽约市偶然发现它，还是写日记，但写日记时你需要小心，因为理论上，这可能是一个在不涉及另一个人的情况下独自解决事情的绝佳空间。但如果你只是用这个空间来重温过去，它本质上就会成为有害反刍的书面记录。正是在这种时候，它实际上弊大于利。因此，要让写日记发挥作用，你真的想把它作为一个空间来
yourself ready to talk about it, then something like this is a good start. I wouldn't say it's everything, but it's a good start. Sometimes it just takes saying it out loud to feel like, okay, this is something I can deal with or work on. So whether you're doing that on the secret telephone, if you happen to stumble upon it in New York City or journaling, but journaling, you want to be careful because in theory, it could be this great space to work through something on your own without involving another person. But if you're using the space to simply rehash the past, it can essentially become a written record of harmful rumination. And that's when it actually harms more than it helps. And so to get journaling to work, you really want to use it as a space to
跳出你平常的视角。这是你自己极其难做到、而在与另一个人的谈话中却非常容易做到的事情。那么，你从那个电话项目中发现了什么？人们讲完秘密后，你在问他们什么？我假设某种后续跟进。这就是它的发展方向。我希望它成为一个真正的研究项目，但到目前为止它是一个艺术项目。我们还没有，我们还没有，你知道，本来的想法是我们会对电话进行编程，以便人们可以回答几个问题。这还没有发生。但是，我们只是在观察人们保守的秘密。它们确实，它们听起来非常有趣。而且，你知道，我已经进行这项研究 10
step outside of your usual perspective. The thing that's extremely hard to do on your own, really easy to do on conversation with another person. So what did you find from that phone project? What were you asking people after they told their secrets? I assume there was some kind of follow-up. This is what it becomes. I wanted it to become a really. research project, but so far it's an art project. We haven't, we haven't, you know, the idea was that we would program the phone so people could answer a few questions. That hasn't happened yet. But just, we've just been looking at the things people keep secret. And they're just, they're quite interesting to listen to you. And, you know, I've been doing this research for 10
年了。听到一个人的声音描述这个秘密，真的是一次非常有趣的经历。我想他们在“火人节”（Burning Man）上做过类似的事情，对吧？或者他们在过去做过，沙漠里的那个电话。是的。那么，关于向治疗师倾诉你的秘密，你怎么看？这种分享是让心理治疗对人们起作用的一部分原因吗？这肯定是其中的成分之一。如果这是你觉得自己愿意做的事情，如果这可能对你管用，这是一种绝佳的方式来谈论这些事情，而没有通常与朋友、家人甚至你的浪漫伴侣谈论这些事情所带来的任何风险。但如果这不是你感兴趣的事，真的任何人
years. And hearing the person's voice describe the secret is, is a really interesting experience. I think they do something like that at Burning Man, don't they? Or they have in the past, the phone in the desert. Yeah. So what are you? about telling your secrets to a therapist? Is that sharing part of what makes therapy work for people? It's certainly one of the ingredients for sure. And if that's something that you feel you'd be comfortable doing, if that might work for you, it's a great way to talk about these things without any of the risks that normally come with talking about these things to friends or family or your romantic partner even. But if that's not something you're interested in, really anyone
都可以做到这一点。就像任何人都可以倾听你的心声并说，这太糟糕了或者我支持你。大多数人都可以提供一点你没有考虑过的建议，因为他们拥有不属于你自己的独特视角。因此，任何你觉得可以放心交谈的人，我们的研究表明，被倾诉的典型反应是积极的。必须有人做出非常负面的反应，你才会后悔这样做。因此，即使是冷淡的反应，人们也觉得有帮助。
can do this. Like anyone can sort of hear you out and say, that sucks or I'm here for you. Most folks can offer just a little bit of advice that you hadn't considered because they have this unique perspective that is not your own. So any person you would feel comfortable talking to, our research shows that the typical response to being confided in is a positive response. And someone has to respond very negatively for you to regret doing so. So even a lukewarm response, people find helpful.
那些工作需要保守秘密的人呢？我指的不是专有信息，而是例如间谍，或者是同意保护消息来源的记者（冒着入狱的危险），或者是可能代表他们知道有罪的某个人的律师，因为工作而保守秘密和保守更个人的秘密是一样的吗？它们可能会交织在一起。当这是你经常考虑的事情，但又不被允许告诉你的配偶时，
What about people whose jobs require them to keep secrets? And I don't mean proprietary information, but people who are spies, for example, or journalists who agree to protect their sources, you know, on pain of going to jail, or lawyers who might represent somebody they know is guilty, is keeping a secret because of your job the same as keeping a more personal secret? They can converge. when it's something that is on your mind a lot, but you're not allowed to tell your spouse,
这就成了一种困难的情况，并且会让人感到孤立。我们的研究表明，无法与其他人谈论你的工作会让人感到孤立。但正如你可能想象的那样，也有一些不同，如果你为工作保守的秘密的性质是你不需要经常考虑的事情，
that becomes a difficult situation and it can feel isolating. We see in our research, it can feel isolating to not be able to talk about your work with other people. But there are some differences, as you might imagine to you, if the nature of the secret you keep for work is it's not something you have to think about a lot,
它似乎不是那么沉重的负担，但如果这是一件大事，你又不能与其他人谈论，你的大脑可能会一次又一次地回到它上面。然后它开始看起来像，这种伤害开始看起来像个人秘密的伤害。某个能够成为间谍并能保守秘密同时还能每天正常工作的人，其心理构成中有什么东西吗？我的意思是，有人研究过这个吗？
it seems not to be very burdensome, but if it's something big and you can't talk about it with other folks, your mind may return to it time and time again. And then it starts looking like the harm starts looking like a personal secrets harm. Is there something in the psychological makeup of somebody who can be a spy, for example, and can keep secrets and still perform every day? I mean, has anybody looked at that?
我会说，一个只要一有想法就把想法说出来的人，可能在那份工作中会过得更艰难，或者甚至可能连接近了解的机会都没有。通常当我们有想法时，如果周围有人，我们会分享它们。这不仅是因为我们想让别人知道我们脑子里有什么。这也是我们与人连接的方式。这也是我们了解世界的方式。你知道，你分享你的想法，然后看看别人有什么回应。但是如果你毫无困难地不分享你脑子里的想法，也许你就能成为一名间谍。
I would say that someone who speaks their mind as soon as they have a thought would probably have a harder time in that job or maybe never even make it close enough to find out. Normally when we have thoughts, if there's people around, we share them. And it's not just because we want people to know what's inside our head. It's just how we connect with people. And it's also how we learn about the world. You know, you share your thought and you see what someone says in response. But if you have no trouble not sharing the thoughts that you're having, maybe you could be a spy.
我们能看出别人在保守秘密吗？我知道已经有关于某人是否在撒谎的研究，但是当某人，你知道，对你隐瞒某些信息时，有什么迹象吗？你怎么知道？因此，在大多数情况下，没有任何线索，因为人们无法读懂你的心思。他们能理解是否有事情让你心烦意乱或困扰你，但他们不能从字面意义上在你的脸上看到秘密。所以，你知道，在某些方面，这很棒。人们无法在你的脸上读出你的秘密，这相当有帮助，那会真的很令人沮丧。因此，研究表明，当我们把两个人带到一个房间里，让一个人对另一个人隐瞒一些事情时，另一个人往往看不出他们在隐瞒
Can we tell when people are keeping secrets? I know there's been research into whether somebody is lying, but are there giveaways when somebody is, you know, keeping some information from you? How would you know? So in most situations, there's not any clues because people can't read your mind. They can understand if something's upsetting you or bothering you, but they can't literally see a secret on your face. And so, you know, in some ways, that's great. That's quite helpful that people can just read your secrets on your face. that would be really frustrating. And so what the studies show is that when we bring two people together in a room and have one person hide something from the other, the other person can't tell that they're hiding
某些事情。观看录像带的人也看不出他们在隐瞒事情。那为什么会这样呢？直觉上，我们会认为也许我们会，人们会不知怎么地看出来。人们会不知怎么地能够看出来。我想当我们脑子里浮现那个画面时，我们有点在想象我们能想象到的最困难的保密情况，有人问你一个与你的秘密直接相关的问题。事实证明，在现实生活中，这种情况并不经常发生。人们不会四处
something often. And people who watch the video recordings can't tell that they're hiding something. And so why is that the case? Intuitively, we'd think that maybe we would, people would somehow tell. People would somehow be able to tell. And I think when we think about that picture in our mind, we're sort of imagining the most difficult secrecy situation we can imagine, someone asks you a question directly related to your secret. It turns out in real life that doesn't happen very often. People don't go around
询问人们这么多，你有没有对你的伴侣不忠？你在童年时期受过虐待吗？这些根本不是我们提出的问题。这些也不是谈话中必然会经常出现的主题，创伤经历。因此，对于那种秘密，真的很难想象别人怎么能不知怎么地知道你在保守它们。现在，如果是你的浪漫伴侣，情况就不同了。如果你在回避某个谈话话题，这是人们试图向他们的浪漫伴侣保守秘密的一种方式、一种常见方式，你的伴侣是能看出来的。如果有一个谈话话题你似乎从来不触及，或者每当它出现时你就会闪躲，
asking people so much, have you ever cheated on your partner? Were you ever abused during childhood? These are just not questions we ask. These aren't topics that necessarily come up in conversation so much, experiences of trauma. And so those kinds of secrets, it's really hard to imagine how someone could somehow know that you're keeping them. Now, if it's your romantic partner, however, here's where things become different. If there's a conversation topic that you're avoiding, which is one way, one frequent way folks try to keep secrets from their romantic partners, your partner's going to be able to tell. If there's just a conversation topic you never seem to touch or sort of dodge whenever it comes up,
他们会注意到这一点的。正如你可能想象的那样，那可不会是什么好事，当我们相信我们的伙伴对我们保守秘密时，这之所以如此伤人，原因之一是我们觉得自己没有被包括在他们的生活中。所以你的新书以一个个人故事开头，讲述了你是如何得知一个重大的家庭秘密的，这个秘密你的父母一直对你保密，直到你成年很久、当你已经在研究秘密心理学时。你能讲讲那个故事吗？它又是如何影响你现在正在做的工作的？是的。所以当我刚开始研究保密性时，我是以一种奇怪的方式进行的，因为我并不是想了解保密性。我是想了解隐喻，你刚才提到了这一点。保密性只是一个例子，人们将秘密描述为沉重、有分量或负担的想法。我有点对人们将哪些秘密与沉重感联系在一起感兴趣。所以我已经做了几年的研究。事实上，有一天我正在哥伦比亚大学做我的工作演讲。所以我在哥伦比亚大学面试我的职位。我觉得进展顺利。
they're going to notice that. And that is not going to be good. as you might imagine, when we believe our partners are keeping secrets from us, one of the reasons that's so hurtful is we feel not included in their lives. So you start your new book with a personal story about how you learned a significant family secret that your parents had kept from you until well into your adulthood when you were already doing research on the psychology of secrets. Can you tell that story and how has that affected the work that you're doing now? Yeah. So when I first started researching secrecy, I was doing it in a sort of strange way because I wasn't trying to learn about secrecy. I was trying to learn about metaphor, which you mentioned earlier. And secrecy was just one example, this idea that people describe secrets as heavy or weighty or burdensome. I was sort of interested in what secrets people associate with a sense of burden. And so I had been doing that research for a couple of years. And in fact, there was one particular day when I was giving my job talk to Columbia. So I'm on my interview at Columbia for my position. And I feel like it goes well.
我向他们介绍了我的秘密研究。然后那天晚些时候，当我实际上仍然和面试的人在一起、在酒吧喝一杯时，我接到了我爸爸的电话。而且，你知道，他从来没有这么晚打过电话。所以我变得非常担心。有什么不好的事情发生了。然后你又打来电话。我说，哦，不。
I present my research on secrecy to them. And then later that night, when I'm actually still with people from the interview, getting drinks at a bar, I get a call for my dad. And, you know, he never calls so late at night. And so I became really concerned. Something bad has happened. And you called again. And I'm like, oh, no.
你知道，也许家里有人去世了之类的。所以我终于在谈话结束后联系上了他，跟每个人说再见。他说，迈克尔，我需要告诉你一件事。你坐下了吗？然后他接着告诉我，我没有坐下。他接着告诉我，他在生物学上不能生育孩子。他告诉我他不是我的亲生父亲。
You know, maybe there's been a death in the family or something. And so I finally get in touch with him after the intercourse. was officially over, said goodbye to everyone. And he says, Michael, I need to tell you something. Are you sitting down? And then he goes on to tell me, I didn't sit down. He goes on to tell me that he's not biologically able to have children. He is telling me that he's not my biological father.
这是在我作为这次面试的一部分展示我的保密研究的一天之后。正如你所能想象的，了解这一点是非常令人震惊的。但很久以后，我基本上在同一时间意识到，我的研究得出了这样的结论：在谈话中隐瞒的行为并不是最困难的，最困难的是必须思考一个秘密，并在你的思想中孤单地与它共存。我意识到我父母的情况确实是这方面的一个完美例证，因为我很久以后问过我的父母，你们是什么时候决定保守这个秘密的？我以为要么是在我出生后不久，要么是在我弟弟出生后不久。我妈妈说，都不是。我们决定永远不告诉我们的孩子，我们可以告诉任何人，但我们
And this is after a day of presenting my research on secrecy as part of this interview. And as you can imagine, that's very shocking to learn about. But much later, I realized essentially at the same time that my research was coming to this conclusion that it's not the act of hiding in conversation that's very difficult, but it's having to think about a secret and live with it alone in your thoughts. And I realized my parents' situation was really a perfect illustration of that because I had asked my parents much later, when did you decide to keep this secret? I assumed it was either after I was born, shortly after I was born, or shortly after my younger brother was born. And my mom said, neither. We had decided that we would never tell our children and we could tell anyone else, but we
永远不会告诉我们的孩子。他们在我们出生之前就决定了这一点。这就是为什么对于秘密，我们真的需要把它定义为一个意图，因为从你打算保守秘密的那一刻起，你就拥有了它。他们在甚至无法隐藏它之前就已经在保守这个秘密了。它已经可以播下怀疑和担忧的种子了。如果我们看起来和我父亲不同怎么办？或者他们需要了解我们的基因。因此，他们告诉我，拥有这个秘密之所以困难，很大程度上并不是因为他们偶尔不得不在谈话中隐藏它。
would never tell our children. And they decided that before we were ever born. And this is why secrecy, we really need to define it as an intention because the moment you intend to keep the secret, you have it. And they were keeping that they had this secret well before they could even hide it. It could already cast doubts and worries. What if we looked different from my father or what they needed to know about our genetics? And so they told me that a lot of what was difficult about having that secret was not that they once in a while had to hide it in conversation.
事实上，那非常罕见。但他们只是偶尔会想到它。某些事情会把它带回他们脑海的最前端。这就是负担的来源。是什么促使你父亲在那个时候告诉你？他知道这对你来说是个重要的日子吗？知道你刚刚结束了一场工作面试吗？是的。所以我了解到，他们可以、他们相当慎重地等到面试结束后才告诉我。不过他们那天想告诉我，
That, in fact, was very rare. But they just had this once in a while think about it. And certain things would bring it back to the top of their minds. And that is where the burden would come from. And what precipitated your father's telling you when he told you? And did he know that this was an important? day for you and that you just finished an interview for a job? Yes. So I learned that they could, they very considerably waited for the interview to be over. They wanted to tell me that day,
因为可能在一两天前，我弟弟发现了这个秘密。他发现这件事的方式是，他正在和一个电话通话，和我妈妈通电话。他们在聊天。她漫不经心地提到她最近和她的父亲（我们的祖父）吵过架。我弟弟说，这太奇怪了。我从来没听说你们争吵过。你们在吵什么？她说，我不能告诉你。这是个秘密。然后他说，好吧，现在你必须告诉我。她说，不，我答应过我永远不会告诉你的。正如你所能想象的，这是一个让人不断追问直到他们、直到他们得知秘密的好方法。他确实做到了。一旦他知道了，他们就必须让我知道，
though, because maybe the day or two days before my brother had found out about the secret. And the way he found out about it was he was on the on a phone, on a phone call with my mom. They were chatting. She mentioned offhandedly that she recently got in an argument with her father, our grandfather. My brother was like, that's so weird. I've never heard a few. to arguing ever. What were you arguing about? And she said, I can't tell you. It's a secret. And he was like, well, now you have to tell me. And she was like, no, I promised I would never tell you. As soon as you can imagine, that's a great way to get someone to keep pushing and pushing until they, until they learned the secret. And he did. And once he learned it, they had to let me know,
但他们想等到面试结束后再告诉我。哇。那么接下来呢？我们需要了解关于秘密的什么？你接下来要研究什么？因此，在思考拥有秘密意味着什么以及你应该用它做什么时，你知道，我们已经暗示过的一件事是与第三方交谈，因为他们可以为你提供一个独特的视角。这真的很难靠你自己找到，这也是当你独自与秘密共存时出现的一部分问题。
but they wanted to wait until the interview was over before they told me. Wow. So what next? What do we need to know about secrets? What are you looking in? to going forward. So in thinking about what it means to have a secret and what you should do with it, you know, one thing that we've sort of alluded to already is talk to a third party because they have a unique perspective that they can offer you. That's really hard to find on your own, and that's part of the problem when you're living alone with a secret.
你有点被困在思考它的唯一方式中了。我们现在正在做的是开始考虑秘密的内容。当我说有 30 个类别的主题时，对于理解哪些秘密比其他秘密对你的伤害更大来说，这个类别太多了。因此，我们现在正在做的是了解人们如何将他们的秘密彼此进行比较。事实证明，人们认为他们的秘密有三个主要维度，秘密是否具有道德性，秘密是否与我们的关系有关，以及秘密是否
You're sort of stuck with your one way of thinking about it. What we're doing now is starting to consider what the secrets are about. And when I say there's 30 categories of secrets, that's too many categories for understanding which secrets hurt you more than others. And so what we're doing now is understanding how people perceive their secrets as sort of compared to each other. And it turns out that people see their secrets as having three primary dimensions, whether it's a secret to moral, whether a secrets related to our relationships, and whether a secret's
与我们的目标有关。他们试图了解这三个不同维度的独特品质或我们对秘密可以有的体验。好吧，谢谢你今天加入我，斯莱皮安博士。这真的很有趣，我保证我不会告诉任何人我们谈论过的话题。谢谢邀请我。你可以在我们的网站 www.combeatingof psychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》以前的剧集，或者在苹果、Stitcher 或你获取播客的任何地方找到。
related to our goals. They're trying to understand the unique qualities of those three different. dimensions or experiences we can have with our secrets. Well, thank you for joining me today, Dr. Sleppian. This has been really interesting, and I promise I won't tell anyone what we talked about. Thanks for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.combeatingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts.
如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件：Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Kondayan）。感谢收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您喜欢我们的节目，请给我们留言评价。如果您有任何建议或对未来节目的想法，可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学话题》由李·薇纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康丹耶安。感谢收听羀单心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留言。